thank you very much we're delighted and
more than delighted very pleased to have
two wonderful gifted smart young people
with us very young a much younger than I
am
we're the same age well you can say that
bill Thank You Jenny
zanuck coin and Beale coin two wonderful
people to one of her friends I'm back in
2000 in a you pull together a very
moving conference
you brought it together journalists
social scientists people with super
ranks background well I was pleased to
be there to participate to talk about to
discuss to debate the issue I raised the
reconciliation in America you have
prepared and added a beautiful book race
reconciliation in America so outstanding
peace thank you it says something about
the distance will come in the progress
with me but we're not there yet we have
not laid down the burden a race but we
own our way and I would love for us to
engage in a conversation the same way we
did back in 2008 so Janet what about you
my dear well I'm just first of all
honored to have you have a conversation
with Bill and me the contributions that
you've made to this country to humanity
are legend and the contribution you made
to our conference when we had our first
conference on race and reconciliation
people are still talking about it the
message you gave us so thank you for
that we wanted to do race and
reconciliation have a conference on the
discussion of race in America because it
seems a taboo subject people don't like
to talk about race while in our
respective
we do like people talk about it all the
time I'm sure white people talk about it
but we never dialogue about it across
the color line and I was always aware of
the discomfort that white people have in
discussing race in mixed groups and
since I was aware of that I thought it
incumbent upon me and Bill joined me and
making White's more comfortable to talk
about it to create an environment where
they could leave their shame if you will
and guilt if you will at the door and we
people of color could leave our blame at
the door and as you said we had academic
movie stars civil rights leaders great
humanitarians coming to talk about this
subject and it came out in this book
that bill and I edited called race and
reconciliation in America and so that
it's shortened for our website we call
it Rory is an acronym of Rory and as I
discovered when we got this acronym that
raw RIA is a wonderful beautiful group
of islands or or mountains rather in
South America so we're all elevating to
that rarefied air as we discuss issues
that are often taboo generally I want to
come back to you in just a moment and I
want you to tell me something about your
background where you grew up what you
were born and where you grew up and how
do you become so committed and so
dedicated to the issue raised and
Reconciliation Avilan let me hear from
you well first of all I really want to
thank you for your service your service
in Congress in your non-government
Secretary of Defense and all of the
great work that you've done over the
years well thank you for being my friend
I've had a great opportunity John that
was a remarkable period of time in my
life to have spent some 28 years in
elective office and then to have the
last four over at the Pentagon was
really the culmination of everything
I've ever done in public sir
I am interested in this subject matter
for variety reasons obviously because of
Janet but I was interested in these
issues long before I met Janet and I
grew up in Maine may be the whitest
state in America but I was a beautiful
state it's a beautiful wonderful place I
visit Maine a few times and great people
break me and but there was there very
few black people in in Maine at least
the one very few that I saw and those
who were in the community family handful
families always lived on the other side
of town and the people said well they're
okay as long as they quote stay in their
place and I never understood what's
staying in their placement but I became
friends I watched one of the the
basketball was very big not big as
Indiana but it was very big and I can
recall 1947 my dad started taking me -
four years old but in 1947 I went to a
ball game the Bangor Rams were playing
and there was one black ball player
Bobby Nelson and he's the one who really
caught my attention because he was so
exciting and the things that he did in
the court was just razzle-dazzle the
enthusiasm that he displayed caught my
attention and then I had the privilege
just a few years later when I was just
eight years later I was playing on the
Bangor Rams as one of the youngest
players ever to start for the team but I
had him in mind and then I had Bob
Talbert who was a one of our my
classmates was really such a gifted
individual and I became very close to
him and then through the basketball
because I would go out to the DAO Air
Force Base which is a Strategic Air
Command base and many many black Airmen
but most of the ones I saw were on the
basketball court and they allowed me to
play with them I was the only white
person in the gym with them and so I got
to understand people on a personal level
and I think all of that contributed to
my wanting to narrow the divide between
blacks and whites in this country I
think the disparity has been so deep
historically the the wretched history
that we've had in this country and the
legacies that still live on
and so having met Janet just a few years
ago and fallen in love with her - to
deal with this issue as a as a
partnership the two of us trying to
bring about a reconciliation in this
great divide that is getting narrower
and narrower but still a long way to go
as you have pointed out and I couldn't
help but think of your role in this when
you talked about you couldn't go to the
library and borrow a book when you were
a young boy and you went back some years
later and you were signing autographs
for your book and that tells you
something about how far we've come
well bill thank you so much you know we
all have stories to tell and your story
is a very powerful story and thank you
for telling it and we share stories and
tell them over and over again to show
the progress that were made and how we
tear down these barriers and these wall
Jenna and know that you were born in
Indiana I was born in Indianapolis
Indiana okay great basketball state I
was born there in 1941 fifteen days
before on the president thank you before
the president declared this is a day
that will live in infamy
shortly after Pearl Harbor had been
struck in our country into the war it
was the days of apartheid America
a lot of people don't like to say it
that way we want to say Jim Crow
segregated but it was an apartheid
America I lived in restricted and
segregated areas my father fought in
World War two and he fought in Patton's
army and when he came home his country
repaid him with the seat on the back of
the bus but the beautiful thing about
this country John is that I the daughter
of that colored soldier could grow up
and marry the Secretary of Defense so
you know we have a wonderful country and
I I often say when I talk about race I
want to give my country some credit
because I love her despite her faults
and because of her promise in her
progress I appreciate that
all right it is amazing to me the
country that we live in it is such a
wonderful place with me so much progress
but there's still a great deal of
progress
to be late this conference took place in
July Oh 8 right July and that's before
the election could the two of you based
on a conference do you have a just doing
the conference do you have a sense that
we were about to take this great leap I
didn't I know mr. Obama was running and
that he was a promising candidate but in
my wildest dreams you have to think now
John you as well we grew up in a
different America than the America of
today the idea that we would ever have a
black man as president of the United
States was incredible to me it was
almost the same as thinking of having
majority rule in South Africa and mr.
Mandela becoming free and becoming
president of South Africa these are two
very remote possibilities in my mind and
the fact that that he is president I'm
still pinching myself and at the time we
did this conference of course the
campaign was going and he was looking
good in the polls but I knew that
perhaps he would never be able to really
confront the issue of race and racism so
bill and I decided to do it because we
once we learned that he had gotten
Secret Service protection long before he
was nominated just when he announced
that he was a candidate that was the
America the the legacy that I remember
of our country and as he was moving
closer to to to realizing the dream I
still thought he wouldn't be able to
talk about it did you feel that no I
think the irony was that he as a black
man had to campaign on the basis that he
quote transcended race and I kept saying
well why does he have to transcend race
why isn't that the responsibility of all
of us who have had a history of imposing
slavery Jim Crow segregation rampant
discrimination why was it his
responsibility to transcend race but he
had that burden and apparently he
carried it the satisfaction of a
overwhelming majority and so it was
surprising
in that sense but I always felt that he
had been restricted where he couldn't
talk openly about race because they
would say well there you go again you're
talking about black issues is that black
issues a separate from white issues in
white America even to this day he cannot
really approach that subject without
being criticized for being too narrow in
scope as the president United States so
he has to back off and only when some
crisis erupts is he called upon that he
has to talk out about an issue whether
it's skipped gates in in Boston or
Cambridge or some other issue that that
erupts so we have felt that he is
restricted in that sense he's the
president United States he has
responsibilities for all of us but we
want to focus on the race issue because
there are such glaring disparities in
income and equal opportunity in terms of
what is taking place within the black
community as far as incarceration this
was our first race and reconciliation
conference we've had two others the
second one was about health and wellness
we were concerned about obesity and so
we devoted the second conference to
talking about health and wellness we had
a number of top doctors we had futurists
Ray Kurzweil and others dealing with the
subject of how we say well and the last
one was just recently we had a entire
conference devoted to justice in America
and the reason we were talking about
justice in America because is such a
disparity black people make up roughly
13% of the population of this country
50% of the prison population there's
something wrong with that formula and
what we have to do is to examine whether
our laws by either design or by
indirection or as a non non calculated
outcome have imposed a a prison sentence
on virtually one out of every three
young black males in this country so if
you look at the numbers one out of every
three between the ages of 18 and 29 or
taking in 34 are going to be in the
penal system what
mean for the black community but what
does it mean for all of us that we are
sending these young people into an
incarcerated situation which they can't
get out I said
and in somewhat a different way I feel
that our society has racialized the laws
John and criminalized black people black
men specifically are disproportionately
represented in prisons and the prison
industrial complex bases its projections
on how many prisons they're going to
build on our children black children's
third grade reading level and if you
look at a black school in a
predominantly black neighborhood and
then you look at a prison just looking
at the pictures you probably wouldn't be
able to tell the difference do you think
the conference that you had on on
Justice helped educate and sensitize
will you come back in and do a report
like this in many ways we were all
like-minded people black and white of
the different disciplines so we were
kind of singing to the choir so what we
did was we shared information exchanged
ideas and we tasked each other to do
something to act it's more than just
examining the problem we know what the
problem is the problem is racism and
disparity we know that we just have to
say it so now that we know this we
stipulated that what do we do what is
the action we take why are we so afraid
going back to do you think this
president is tied to a stand it that
other president have not been free that
was free to say if what they wanted to
say but when it come to race because of
his race his color I think it's not free
I think he's restricted I think that he
is restricted and what he can say
because he then opens himself up to
criticism that he's now just talking as
a black president not as an American
president and I think that's what we're
really trying to deal with here we have
Black History Month and when we talk
about this we talked to Morgan Freeman
who's our friend who did an introduction
for Janet's play inanimate which we
should talk about also but he is raising
issue why is it just one month for black
Americans is
and there are 11 months for white
America I mean why isn't it part of our
entire history some people sort of joke
and say we selected eeeh - oh my - oh I
heard that a great deal a smart and so I
think that the president can't really
and shouldn't get you know confined by
this but we feel that we have an
obligation to speak out about this I
feel special obligation because I was a
lawmaker as well and I helped write some
of those laws that are in fact they have
a discriminatory impact they may not
have been designed that way I certainly
didn't think so but when you write a law
that says if you have five grams of
crack cocaine will get you the same
prison sentence if you have 500 grams of
powder there's something wrong with that
picture because crack is used by the
inner city of blacks as such and the
powder used by suburban White's more
likely but you've got such a disparity
in terms of how the impact is that
that's one of the reasons why the way
the war on drugs has been conceived and
implemented executed it has a
disproportionate effect upon black
people and so that's an issue in terms
of black people tend to get longer
sentences than a white person I mean you
can go through all of the issues but
basically there was a great disparity
and once you it's tough enough in this
economy to get a job but if you're a
black person and you have a criminal
record your chances of getting a job are
almost nil and that means you're going
to be confined to a ghetto whether
economic ghetto or a physical one as
such and you're never going to get out
of there and you're going to be surveyed
by the by the police that you're more
likely more likely to come back into the
prison system because you're going to
turn to drugs because you have no hope
at cetera centers so what we want to do
is to raise the issue look at our
criminal justice system we had Eric
Holder who came to kick off the the
conference we had Justice Breyer who
came and talked about mandatory
sentencing etc so we hope that the two
of us can contribute to raising the
level of awareness and to raise the the
debate level to the point where perhaps
we can make a difference thank you I
just want to add to what Bill has said
about your
can mr. Obama President Obama talk about
race and racism and it's almost it's
almost like none of us of color can talk
about race or racism one as Jon Meacham
of Newsweek magazine said on Meet the
Press white people get queasy when black
people talk about race to racism and why
legend why is we live in a society in
spite of all of the changes in spite of
all of the progress that with me that we
still want to speak to issue a race
under the table in some dog :
I think it's shame I think when you
really know our history and how unfair
it's been the white unearned advantage
the twin evils of white supremacy and
black inferiority when you realize that
these are not only evils but lies when
you check the history to see that the
enslavement and black people was the
economic engine that built this country
how proud would you be if you were white
to realize all the advantages you have
with a disadvantage of other people they
made us illegal and subhuman in order to
justify their Christian notions of
enslavement presidents from our very
first president even Abraham Lincoln
he's called our great Emancipator
he had negative views on black people he
was inviting ah the Union or the South
Fork for four hours liberation he was
fighting to hold his Union together and
we got free in the process so you know I
think when when White's look at that if
they look at it so much the history has
been revised changed obscured but when
they look at the truth the truth is that
there's a Hebrew word called a met means
truth the truth is hard to take and some
people can take it you know those of us
that come from sort of a biblical
background religious heritage we always
said the truth was such a free any will
and youto the truth when you cross that
bridge and you got your head crack
dr. King told the truth when he spoke in
1963 when he marched with you he told
the truth we're all telling the truth
but who was it that said can't take the
truth
can't handle the truth who is that we
want to do is tell the truth but tell it
with love because we're all in this
together
I'm as red white and blue as bill is Red
Riding Hood I love this country and I
think that we continue our divisiveness
not only black and white orientation
gender religion we divide ourselves to
make ourselves vulnerable I think these
kind of divisive behaviors are affecting
our national security we don't fight
conventional Wars really anymore an
enemy could see our weaknesses and our
vulnerabilities to see where we're
divided and conquer us well I think the
conclusion of this unbelievable
conference that you had released stated
and as I read the findings and what
people say at bottom we're really one
family we're one people and what I said
but you said in that book John at that
conference you said get in the way no
make trouble all right Richard Douglas
good trouble good trouble necessary
trouble agitate and we all still need to
you know but there people are discussing
today you hear bill from time to time we
were saying fight why should you talk
about race so you know you elected a
black president
it's we live in a post-racial Society
let's just move on what do you say to
that well I think many people look at
this and say why are you going back into
history we've come such a long way and
by the way yes there was a black man in
the White House and that is true except
there are millions of people who were
living lives of quiet desperation based
upon past policies I was struck most
recently by that story of the young boy
in Pittsburgh as I recall who was
walking down the street suddenly a car
pulls up and three white men jump out
and start
after him he starts to run will they
catch him they I think they tasered him
they beat him and the rationale was well
he didn't stop because we were police
not in uniform undercover and he didn't
hear them say that but they said he had
some threatening object in his hand it
was a sprite bottle some kind of a soda
pop and this goes on and on and on you
can cite case after case of how many
black men have been shot unarmed one
pulling a wallet out to show his
identification others coming from other
circumstances but you don't I mean this
is something that's still real and and
we have to come to grips with it
janet has a play I mentioned before
called anonymity and we have some really
young talented actors who are playing
the role of Anne Frank and Emmett Till
and you have these young black actors
who were out doing rehearsal and I find
myself cautioning them they may wear a
sweatshirt or they wear baggy pants I
say when you leave tonight don't run
don't run to your car don't run to the
truck and get the Metro and walk and
it's almost a it's a parental fear of my
part to say be careful because you can
still be seen as being a threat even
though you're just walking down the
street if you have to be black and
happen to address in a certain way
you're automatically suspect so it
continues and what we have to do is to
educate ourselves enlighten ourselves
say yes there are stereotypes that we
have about black people but we've got to
break down the stereotypes and we got to
look at people as people and not assume
that someone is a criminal because he
happens to be a certain color or a
certain religion and the religion part
comes in with an anaemic because then
frankly there's a rise of anti-semitism
taking place here in this country but
globally as well so it's all about hate
and what we want to do is you want to
speak out against hate in whatever form
if it's about color it's about religions
by the ethnicity of preference sexual
preference whatever we ought to be
speaking out against that saying let's
look at people as people and see that we
are all in this together and that we
ought to try to reach higher levels of
goodness and decency and humanity you
know dr. King said on one occasion maybe
say don't serve occasion
that hate is to have a burden to bear
do you suggest coming to their point in
our country that someday that we would
be able to lay down the burden the hate
and maybe just maybe America would
emerge as the model for the rest of the
world Janet is that Frank who always
believes the goodness of people I'm sort
of it's never gonna stop
anyway she's the optimist I'm the
pessimist well I've seen great progress
because I lived in a segregated society
and now I live in the dream I'm living
the dream so I don't know I think a lot
of it is genetic
I think it's ingrained in us as as human
beings so you think it's part of our DNA
yeah and I think we have to manage it no
I think a superior beings and lightin
beings I think we have to manage that
and there's a wonderful other Hebrew
saying is to come alone that is to
repair the world to finish God's work he
didn't make us perfect so our job is to
do the best we can to get to that
profession the Tobias thing as you're
calling your mission you just feel like
this sense of this is the thing to do
and you must do it now go back to dr.
King again he over he used to say the
time is always right to do right so you
think the time it was right it's always
right is it my calling it is like
breathing in and breathing out it's it's
the right thing to do is to stand up for
what is right I hate bullies I hate
injustice and certainly coming from my
background I feel it a noble obligation
it's my responsibility in many ways I
have overcome so if I get there if I
come from the bottom from a
single-parent mother on welfare living
in a government project in a segregated
America and I can get here and be
interviewed by you here in this great
city I have a responsibility to give
back to share to lift up to take the
risk
I haven't taken nearly the risk that you
took you took this with your life you
put your life and your principles on the
line
I'm just talking and hoping to walk it
I'm proud of my husband for what he's
doing I he was ready before he got to me
he was already involved in righteousness
and the civil rights movement but I am
so proud of him and and and need more
men like him we need white people to
talk that because as we said earlier
every time we talk about racism and
injustice they say there they go again
and their eyes glaze over but when men
like my husband bill Cohen and Doug
Blackmon David Shoen when they speak out
our rabbi when he speaks out they listen
they pay attention so I am so grateful
for him and and his commitment is what
Bill come from a great background and
knowing him over the years and reading
about him knowing where he grew up and
Bill I'm struck I tell you where things
struck about you the date that you were
born August 28 yeah it you know it's to
me sometime I think about that date and
what happened to meet you on that date
you know years later after you were born
on the march on Washington 63 it may be
like a burden that when you sort of
sometimes I call it a spirit of history
that sin dates and time and places sort
of track you down some just maybe just
maybe those forces and tractor to me
down I've just at this time I think it
was totally coincidental
I believe it was by almost by accident
that we ran into each other way back to
Missouri before
well I was deeply involved in the House
Judiciary Committee at that time during
the impeachment resolutions that we were
looking at and I had to get back to
Maine and my staff said well gee you
ought to stop in Boston this has got a
great show and it's a very popular
program and you should be interviewed
and talked to the people about what
you're doing and I was not going to go
that day because I was really suffering
from a terrible head cold eyes I was
just getting worn down with all the and
the pressures involved but I went
got to Boston went to the studio and
there while I was getting a drink of
water and blowing my nose before going
on the air she walks by and that's when
we first met so her first image of me
was not exactly a graceful moment in my
beautiful moment but in any event we
first met and that's when the sparks
started to fly at that point I saw how
how talented she was and and what a
great interviewer she was at that point
I became very very attracted to her bill
was working on the Judiciary Committee
in the house on the impeachment of
Richard Nixon and you had just been on
the cover of Time magazine and Andy
Young our mutual friend and a young who
was serving with you in the Congress had
told me about Bill coming through New
England because the kind of show I did
was a talk show and they wouldn't let me
a woman do the serious substantive
interviews so Andy said talk to bill
Cohen on his way through to me and he'll
he'll talk to you he'll enlighten you on
what's going on and I looked at bill and
I I said Cohen is your name Cohan or
Cohen because he has the map of Ireland
on his face and I later learned that his
mother was Irish and his father is
Jewish which makes it somewhat unusual
for me because with that combination of
course I have the quintessential Jewish
name but my mother having been Irish and
not having converted means that I'm not
Jewish
thank you it's wrong but I was raised in
I went to six years of Hebrew school but
I was not really ever considered Jewish
and it really kind of sensitized me to
what other people who were discriminated
against because to the Gentiles I was
Jewish to the Jewish people I was a
Gentile and I fit in neither category so
it was a I think a character-building
experience for me and I think it made me
much more sensitive to people who have
to labor under the scrim natori of
practices and policies but I want to get
back to talk about Janet's life because
what was so for me inspiring about her
life is how she was able to overcome all
that that up south discrimination that
took place in her home state or the KKK
had its headquarters
to go from being a young girl living
next to the big oh by the way who played
basketball outside correctly yes that to
go and become a model to meet with dr.
King and have him as her mentor to meet
Muhammad Ali who gave her I think one of
the great instructive moments of her
career I'll let her talk about it but
when she was parading around as a
crowning queen in a parade in Chicago
she saw her friend who was had been
stripped of his title and he said meet
me down at the end of the of the parade
and I'll let you up I'll turn it over to
you because I'm giantess old and lengthy
Stuart Welch other story sharing a story
it's important I met dr. King and
Muhammad Ali the same year 1966 in
Chicago Muhammad was having great
difficulty because the federal
government had stripped him of his his
title as heavyweight champion of the
world and because he didn't want to
serve in Vietnam he would resisted the
draft and I saw him at the end of this
parade that I was in and he drove me
home and I was sort of crying because he
didn't have his entourage with him and
he looked you know he didn't look sad
but he was alone and I said Muhammad
they've taken everything from you the
government has stripped you of your
livelihood everything they've taken it
all he said on Janet they haven't taken
everything for me they haven't taken me
from me and he said you I know you want
to be something someday never want
something so much that you wanted more
than you love yourself so when they take
it from you they take you from you and
it was 24 years okay that wisdom story
good advice oh why don't we pause for
break and we'll be right back
afterwards sends several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with William and Janet
Lang Hart Cohen and representative John
Lewis in a moment tomorrow your chance
to talk to Karl Rove live on book TV
starting at 10:00 Eastern the former
senior advisor to President Bush and
current Fox News contributor will take
your phone calls emails and tweets on
his new memoir courage and consequence
one afterwards former defense secretary
and Senator Bill Cohen and wife Janet on
race relations in America they're
interviewed by Congressman John Lewis
and all this weekend live coverage of
this year's Tucson Festival of Books
fund the entire weekend schedule at book
TV org and get the latest book TV
updates on Twitter afterwards with
William and Janet Lang Hart Cohen and
representative John Lewis continues
let's continue our dialogue our
discussion on a question raised in
reconciliation in America we have made
progress no one but no one can deny that
fact I know as someone who grew up in
rural Alabama in the forties and the
fifties as a young child I saw
segregation and racial discrimination I
tasted a bitter fruits the racism and I
didn't like it but when people said
nothing has changed today you know bill
Janet I said to them come and walk in my
shoes
I'll show you change and that cannot be
denied so what where do we go from here
where do we go from here to continue to
build on the progress that was made but
in order to build on the progress that
was made we have to continue to tell the
story exactly to remember to never
forget not get over it
people often tell black people to get
over it and that's history well history
lives in us the legacy of our lives now
is that history but I want to ask you a
question of my background is that of a
journal
and I'm curious to ask you a question
because your living history sitting
right here with us you're celebrating
150 years of snick what is it 45 years
of cussing that bridge
what did you summon the courage to face
those people with the dogs and the guns
and the epithets and all the things they
were throwing at you spitting on you
throwing urine at you where did you
summon that courage I don't think I was
being courageous but I saw I didn't like
it and my folks my mother and my father
my grandparents my great-grandparents
had told us in a sense to be quiet
there's this grown folk business don't
get in trouble don't get anyway
but when I heard of wandered the King
jr. I heard his voice on already yo and
I felt like he was speaking directly to
me saying you too can do something and I
got in the way and sobbing getting in
the way now for more than 50 years are
you scared now you come to that point
where you lose that sense of fear if
something is so good so right and so
necessary that you have to continue to
push on and that's what I think we all
have to do continue to push continue to
bill have you reconciled with any of the
white people that were calling you names
since those days well I have had an
opportunity to meet some of the
individuals not only they called me
names and he would have had me arrested
in jail for one of the people that beat
a group of us on the Freedom Ride in May
of 1961 to be exact it was May 9 1961 in
rokkyo South Carolina after President
Barack Obama was elected and inaugurated
then but my age came to Washington and
to visit my office on Capitol Hill and
said Mr Lewis I'm one of the people who
attacked you in Rock Hill and I want to
apologize will you please forgive me and
he started crying and he told me that
his son had been trying to convince him
to do this for many years
and finally he did uh so we hug and
embrace him and we both cried but
knowing you John you probably forgave
him before he asked yeah I don't I don't
have I think you know this what this is
all about that's what this book is all
about reconciliation raised in
reconciliation in America that you come
to the point where you have the power to
forgive and be reconciled and and move
on but don't you think in order to
reconcile the oppressor must come
forward and acknowledge the problem what
he's done the transgression and in any
case apologize but if they can't
apologize acknowledge what they've done
because we can forgive it is important
it is important that's why it's
important for us to continue to declare
along the dialogue I'd like to come back
to something you mentioned about the
magic of dates August 28th that was a
very important date in Janet's career
because she was about to enter a an
integrated high school and brown against
Board of Education had been decided so
that she was equal now and she was
entitle in the equal education and yet
she saw what happened to Emmett Till and
most white people have no idea who he
was but he changed the course of
American history he was a young boy from
Chicago went down to Mississippi to
visit his grandparents and while he was
there he committed the crime of
whistling at a white woman for which he
was untaken out and brutally brutally
beaten disfigured and unclenched his
mother had the courage to bring his body
back home and have an open-casket
ceremony because she wanted the the
world to see what happened to him and
what they do to black people and that
changed Janet's life in a very
significant way because she decided
after she saw that picture in Jet
magazine yes that she was not going to
go to anyway school I was I was all
excited that summer as bill said after
the nine white men decided I was equal
to the white girls or white kids and I
was all excited about going to an
integrated school I wanted
get to know them I wanted what was
perceived to be a better education and
after we got word that summer that
Emmett Till had been murdered I thought
I'd better stay in my all-black
environment and get as much of my own
roots if that was the kind of world that
had to face and I saw something happen
in our community and you probably saw it
in yours John when we got word in
Indiana that Emmett had been murdered
for whistling at a white woman in
Mississippi I watched my mother hold my
little brother closer
I watched the light go out of the eyes
of our elders because of the fear and
the resentment and I can't tell you how
proud we were when Rosa Parks that
following December sat down on that bus
and it wasn't because her feet were
hurting she was a seamstress she was
thinking about what they did to Emmett
Till and of course you know the history
better than I that was the beginning of
the dr. King movement it was a turning
point a major turning it was a turning
point he didn't want to do it did he
reluctant person to but he was called
upon and sometime we are call upon like
I think the two of you have been call
upon to play a role and you have to play
it and you're playing it well and what's
wonderful thank you but what's wonderful
I get to play this role with Bill we do
this together and this bracelet that we
wear we designed for this first
conference it's ironically black and
white and it says race and
reconciliation and then there's one that
says the dream you know because we love
dr. King so much in his his mission and
we gave it away at the conference to all
of the participants so that they could
remember and they could flaunt this kind
of unity this endless ring the seamless
circle and it's so ironic that Bill and
I would be doing this together because
it took another US Supreme Court
decision to allow us to marry within our
age of reason within whether we were
adults in 1967 and it wasn't until 1967
that that same court the Supreme Court
decided that we could marry I thought
you were teenagers into this
I line up my we had we had all these
laws special in southern states that
blacks and whites could not marry right
can I stay in the same hotel and write
in the same tax again and I think it's
so fitting to have this bracelet of
black and white the dream it is an
effort to finish the work to fulfill the
dream of dr. King when you say finish
the work people often say about us black
people have come a long way and I say
we've always been capable of being
doctors and lawyers and television
personalities and congressmen and
secretaries of state and presidents it
is white people who have come a long way
and because of it America has traveled a
great distance and that is the distance
that we celebrate with this bracelet and
the further distance is what we're
hoping for in our dialogues and I want
to come back to Emmett because this is
really important to the two of us janet
has written a play called a man Emmett
and Frank and Emmett Till having an
imaginary conversation in a place called
memory and this is important because it
deals with what we talked about in race
and reconciliation it deals with hatred
how hate kills and as a matter of fact
the play was supposed to have premiere
opened at the Holocaust Museum last year
last June and while we were waiting for
Janet to arrive and I was talking on the
phone with her a car drove up and a man
an elderly man got out of that car he
walked into the museum when I was about
30 feet away and a black security guard
pulled open the door to help him and the
man picked up a rifle and killed the
security guard and then a security guard
other ones opened fire on him but the
irony was that on that day in which a
play that really talks about how hate
kills institutionalized hatred in
Germany during Nazi period time
and in this country with the Klan and
other groups who were terrorizing black
people to talk about what has happened
and what needs to happen what
call-to-action has to take place to have
that interrupted by a man who was 88
years old carrying the burden you talk
about of hatred and killing an innocent
young officer who had a young family
that really kind of captured why we are
committed to talking about race and
reconciliation why we're committed of
taking this play and an Emmitt and
making sure that young people understand
what has happened in the past how an
Anne Frank and who she symbolized to
millions of people who were wiped out by
Adolph Hitler of Emmitt who was one just
one boy who was brutally murdered but
that was just had take place thousands
more than thousands have taken place we
want these two characters to be taught
in the school systems to say everybody
knows about Anne Frank not many know
about Emmett Till but if you look at
their lives in terms of totally
different countries different races
religions different backgrounds they
both were treated the same way by the
oppressors the commonalities of how they
were treated and Nazi Germany the Jewish
people would have to step off the
sidewalk and couldn't look at German in
the eye the same for us here in this
country a black person couldn't look a
white person in the eye in the south
they'd have to step off the sidewalk
they had curfews for the Jewish people
in Nazi Europe they had sundowner rules
for us here in this country we had to be
back on the plantation couldn't be in
town after sundown when you go to a
movie theater the Jewish people in Nazi
Europe would have to sit way up in the
balconies well where do we sit in the
crosnes we clog the crosnes we'd have to
sit way in the politic Rose nestled the
Buzzard the Buzzard roost
the Jewish people had to wear the Star
of David on the front and back of their
clothes so the Nazis could see them
coming and going we didn't have to wear
any patches pigmentation skin color was
enough to discern who we were so it's
those parallels that I talk about in the
play
Emmit two young teenagers she was 15 he
was 14
lived in societies that didn't allow
them to survive that couldn't protect
them and it's so interesting that I feel
I embody both of them because as bill
said I'm the same age as Emmett Till he
and I were born the same year his death
affected me because what it taught me
even though I knew about racism my
mother got me ready in the cradle for
racism but at 14 at his murder
it taught me what my country tis of thee
thought of me a person of color and Anne
Frank's murder and the murder of six
million taught me man's inhumanity to
man so between the two of them I thought
there's something there and then being a
person of color having witnessed racism
and being a person of color with a
Jewish last name I've witnessed
anti-semitism but do you ever wonder do
you ever contemplate and City is a high
and why how could people do what a
Hitler dear it's a whole segment of the
population a hacker or people do what I
did to black people do people color in
American South yes because not enough
good people stand up stand up
when you see hatred start to surface
Madeleine Albright secretary Albright
and I co-chaired a study into how we can
prevent genocide from taking place in
the future and there are warning signals
you see it take place and again in Janis
play it all fits together you start to
dehumanize the other person you degrade
them you make them less than human
you call them subhuman you treat them as
three-fifths of a human you give them
tales you give them horns in all the
cartoons and characters so you diminish
their humanity and that is the beginning
of the process of then starting to
marginalize or murder or eliminate them
so you have some who want to destroy
people that we saw with Hitler you have
others who want to down
dominate the blacks in this country for
industrial purposes for their slave
labor or for entertainment or whatever
it might be you have the oppressor who
does the same thing in each case and the
first thing is to reduce you to
something less than a human being and so
what we want to do is to say that that
can take place especially in economic
and tough times whenever there are
economic stresses people without jobs
people without hope they look to blame
other people and scapegoats and it's up
to us to speak out against that saying
we know we have economic difficulties
right now but what we have to always
hold on to is our humanity and not allow
whatever impulses might like very deep
in our DNA we've got to suppress those
and talk about who we are as human
beings and what that means in terms of
our responsibility to speak out and not
allow the haters to get the megaphone
and start dominating the airwaves or the
conversation without challenge our
beloved Martin King used to say I won't
remember the hateful words of my enemies
I'll remember the silence of my friends
so do you think at this particular
Junction in the history that sometimes
we've been too quiet and too silent when
we see things happening to people and no
one said a word at one time we had these
unbelievable writers and investigative
reporters and journalists who really
talk and they have politicians who come
on the scene and well you can be
penalized for talking about race if
you're black I've lost a many a job for
standing up for what I thought was right
I would hope that if I were a white
woman I would stand up against injustice
when I worked in Boston as the
television personality that I was
telling you about I was living there in
Boston's not so finest hour
it was quarter to busing days when white
mothers were stoning black children on
school buses
think I'm the only one who remembers
that I can't find any footage on that
John I think you remember that don't you
yes so it's it's it's it's that it's so
many other things that I remember that
make me wonder again is it in our DNA
that it's something that has to be
managed and yes we've come a long way
but we still have further to go just as
we were saying the president seems like
he can't talk about racism he has extra
security he's had more threats on his
life we're all wondering about the
motivations of the tea parties I don't
wanna say that wrong
well tea party yours there you keep that
separate the party time being no look at
our history that's how they that's a
separate discussion I think in terms of
you know linking everybody and that's
something we but do you think as
something is embedded in the very vain
of our society that is so it's engraved
and that we must continue to work in
every single day every hour every minute
every second breath every breath look at
our history 244 years of slavery about a
hundred and fifty years of apartheid how
do we let go of that so easily that's
still in us when we go to school to
study we have to go to a book to study
math we have to go to a book to study
English we don't have to go to a book to
study race and our place in this country
we all know the rules
somehow we blacks learn the rules of
what our so-called places and
expectations and what we can dream for
and whites have their place and they
know it we all know it I remember being
a and in my first year of college
we shared classes together but it went
when it was time to go on a date we are
divided based on race we didn't say
anything we just knew the rules so it's
so ingrained in us historically
culturally and I think as far as
humanity is concerned we're all
discriminate
in the positive sense we know the
difference and then people like to be
with people like themselves that they're
most comfortable with but that shouldn't
give them the right to oppress and hurt
and deny opportunities of others do you
think that will come to that point for
another generation of leave especially
young people young blacks young wise
Latino as I age in America a Native
American that they have come they born
in a different time in a different
period in there and they're sort of
sailing against the wind they're going
against some of the paths and they're
not tied down they've not carrying this
heavy load to baggage and that and
that's good but they shouldn't remember
that the baggage was carried they
shouldn't forget that it couldn't recur
that it couldn't come back we think the
Nazis are gone all we had to do was
remember the shooting at the museum the
day my play was in dress rehearsal that
it's just underground it never goes away
so we have to be vigilant freedom isn't
free we have to fight for it every day
I'm gonna come back to the play and
because I think that's an important play
to have people to see to have this
conversation between Anne Frank and
Emmett Till now after the play do you
put provide an opportunity for for young
people and others to engage in dialogue
and quest night janitors I mean this is
her play and she attends almost all of
the performances and then has a QA
period following that a discussion with
the audience to say what did they think
what did they agree disagree with what
about the historical lessons involved
and so she she is in her element
following the play third grade teacher I
really wanted to teach school and I
wrote to play for young people the same
ages as Anne Frank and Emmett Till I
think we have to get to their minds and
hearts while they're young by the time
they get to be our age they're so shaped
and formed with their biases and
prejudices hard to unring that Bell
but I wrote it for the children because
they are the future and they should be
less burdened with it and I think I lost
my train of thought early when I wanted
to make the point that a lot of people
and I can say black people younger
people who say in their 30s and 40s with
children they're aware of our history
but they don't want to burden their
babies with it you know it's almost like
saying there really is a Santa Claus
everything's all right but there isn't a
Santa Claus racism exists and it
persists and at some point parents are
going to have to determine when they
share this burden of history this the
societal problem this cancer that we
have called racism in our society it's
just been Jim Crow has just been really
divine designed it's morphed into
something else we called it something
when you and our kids now it's called
something else
so in fact Michelle Alexander who was at
our last conference has written a book
called the new Jim Crow mass
incarceration in the age of
colorblindness it's a very powerful book
talking about the Jim Crow lives just
now it's incarceration as opposed to
segregation and slavery so it's in a
different form it's in a different form
form but it's still there so we have
lots of work to do John well we must
continue to work and I really want to
thank the two of you for your great work
your great leadership your vision for
your inspiration and I enjoyed being
with you and continue to tell the story
continue to build one America for we are
one people one family the American
family you keep working up on Capitol
Hill to make that a reality